Project Tango runs
on Android devices.
And you can use the
same tools that you
use to develop regular
apps to respond
to changes in the device
position and orientation.
Hi.
My name is Nikolai.
And in this episode,
I'm going to show you
how to use the Java
programming language, Android
Studio, and the Rajawali
Java 3D Graphics Library
to implement motion tracking.
In this demo, we are
going to move around
a sample cityscape using
the pose data that we
get from the motion
tracking system.
Let's get started.
Once you're set up,
launch Android Studio
and import the motion
tracking Java project.
You can see the App folder,
which contains the demo app.
And above that, you will
see the Tango Utils folder,
which is used to expose
the motion tracking data
in a format the Rajawali
library can use.
In the AndroidManifest.XML
file, we
request the permission
for the camera,
add the user's library
element for Project Tango,
and disable automatic
screen orientation.
We will use the app's
Gradle build script
to wire up the Tango SDK,
Rajawali, and Tango Utils.
In the script, we add the SDK
here, the utilities library,
and lastly, the
Rajawali library.
Before we start, we will
add a Rajawali surface view
to the Layout XML
file in the project.
This view will be used to render
the 3D content on the screen.
In the motion tracking
activity class,
we have created a
reference to this view
to be used later by
our render object.
To render our cityscape
scene with Rajawali,
we need to extend the Rajawali
renderer abstract class.
And we do that in
the motion tracking
Rajawali renderer file.
This class will allow us
to configure what to show
and how to render it.
First, we set up the
lights for the scene
so the 3D objects
will be visible.
Then we import a 3D object,
the cityscape, as an OBJ file
and render that in the scene.
We need to set the
position of the 3D world
relative to the device.
Motion checking in Project
Tango always starts at the 000
coordinate, the origin,
and that will, by default,
be the ground plane
for the 3D world.
However, we want the city to
be aligned with the floor.
And since I hold the device
1.3 meters above the floor,
I set the height offset
to minus 1.3 meters here.
You might want to change
that value to something
that works for you.
This is where we update the
pose in the rendered scene.
And we use the
utilities function
to convert the pose data
to Rajawali's camera
pose In the main
activity class, we now
connect the renderer to the
RenderView in the setup GL view
and renderer helper function.
And to receive the data
from Project Tango,
we need a reference
to the tango object.
And we call new tango
to get this object.
We also need a reference to
the tango configuration object,
which we get from calling our
helper function setup tango
config.
Now we set up the Project
Tango event listeners
in order to receive
the pose updates.
A pose is what
Project Tango uses
to describe the user's
location in a 3D space.
We also need to remember
to handle the life
cycle of Project Tango.
And we do that in the on
resume and on pause methods.
When we get a new pose,
we update the camera
in the Rajawali renderer here.
This will make the camera
follow the motion of the device.
Now we are ready to compile
and launch this project.
Let's have a look at how that
works out on a Project Tango
enabled device.
And there you have it.
Project Tango provides
mobile devices
with three-dimensional
motion tracking,
and Rajawali provides you with
an easy-to-use 3D rendering
engine in Java.
Visit our Google+ community
and join us in our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]